flash fact fans are bothered by one hard
to miss plot hole in the flash are they
just hungry to complain or does this
plot Point actually get left behind in
the dust spoilers ahead The Flash is a
superhero movie that juggles a lot of
big ideas and with all the balls it has
in the air it's not all that surprising
that the film might drop one or two but
one major hard to ignore plot hole is
the fact that the flash uses much of its
first half to establish a very specific
limiter to Barry Allen's speed powers
and then spends the rest of the movie
ignoring it altogether from his very
first moment on screen it's clear that
Barry needs to eat a whole lot to
maintain his Pace with great power in
his case comes great metabolism and if
he neglects to keep up with his calorie
intake his power is effectively vanish
this creates tension in the opening
Hospital rescue scene as a nearly
de-powered Berry has to smash a Free
Falling vending machine for a super fast
emergency refueling session the Flash's
constant need to feed is further
established when the younger alternate
Universe Berry gets his powers and finds
out that his body is screaming for
sustenance after just a short super
speed session I call it the speed force
caused me to burn a tremendous amount of
calories so I'm just a black hole of
snacks with this elaborate setup it's
easy to assume that the protagonist's
specific dietary requirements will come
into play later down the line however
around the Time Michael Keaton's Batman
enters The Fray the whole calorie
counting thing starts disappearing into
the background to the point that every
flash in the Final Act can function for
absurd amounts of time without so much
as a chocolate bar the food situation is
still somewhat in play in the movie's
second act as younger Berry continues to
eat whenever he can we see him noisily
wolfing down Bruce Wayne's Multiverse
explaining spaghetti dish commandeering
his other self's coffee mug and even
accidentally overhearing elderberry's
reason for time traveling while tucking
into a snack in a nearby hidey hole
however when push comes to shove neither
Berry seems to remember that they
constantly need to refuel in the massive
final fight against General forces both
versions of The Flash spend a prolonged
period In the Heat of the battle without
having a single bite to eat raining
blows and throwing lightning blasts all
over the place with gusto and that's
before the younger flash figures out how
to time travel once that aspect of the
plot comes into play they start
rewinding the same battle over and over
once again with no food in sight though
the main flash soon realizes that it's
futile to fight the battle with slightly
different tactics he still runs the
gamut more than once and based on what
the early parts of the movie establish
he should be pretty drained by the time
he stops still even if we assume that
the flashes simply had a huge meal
before the big battle it still doesn't
explain the younger Berry's exploits as
the main flash keeps imploring him to
stop his time Shenanigans the alternate
universe one just keeps going running
through the same time Loop over and over
again not only does he rewind himself
back into battle non-stop but he becomes
more injured with every turn forcing his
body to heal around the debris that gets
stuck in him at no point is there any
indication that he eats even nearly
enough to fuel any of these meta-human
feeds and then there is the dark flash
alternate Barry's older self who has
been stuck in the same self-imposed time
Loop for an unspecified absurdly long
time just like his younger self he's
extremely driven and the implication is
that he's been trying to figure out how
to win the battle non-stop all these
years the battlefield still doesn't have
any food so it remains unclear how he
manages to do this without any calories
after all he's clearly not stuck in a
Timeless State himself considering that
he's aged and deteriorated into a
monstrosity of course the flash is all
about time travel and the younger alt
Universe Barry specifically says that he
considers time meaningless so it's
technically possible that he and dark
flash keep leaving the battlefield for a
quick Burger run every few hundred miles
However the fact that the movie's final
third doesn't address the various
flashes need to maintain their calorie
intake breaks the very rules the movie
itself took great pains to establish